in labs around the world scientists are
racing to understand the new coronavirus
they want to know where it came from and
how to stop it and to get the answers
they need they've turned to bets 75% of
emerging infectious disease came from
animal that can carry the viruses
without symptom they look healthy but it
but best can transmit wireless to other
animal to human doctor sue Capone has
been studying these viruses for years at
Thailand's Tula Longhorn University the
corona virus spreading now she has
almost a 100% DNA match with another one
found in Betts and she hopes that study
and wildlife can help us prevent and
control outbreaks and humans
dr. super corn helped decode the genome
for the first confirmed case of the new
virus outside China behind this door
researchers are working with patient
samples of the corona virus and they're
taking steps to make the fragments safer
to work with by killing the virus but
keeping its DNA intact we can't go in
here because it's too dangerous ty
doctors say a new approach of treating
some of those who do get sick appears to
be working
using a cocktail of flu and anti HIV
drugs
that's after one Chinese woman treated
in a hospital in Bangkok recovered but
other patients didn't and the government
says it's too early to say whether that
mix of drugs is effective in medical
system we can only do a case report so
we send this report to many medical
journals and also many research and
medical schools you know in order for
them to continue further and a treatment
can't come soon enough
Thailand is seen as one of the country's
most at risk from this new virus because
of the number of Chinese visitors it
receives each year and because in recent
weeks some came from Wuhan the epicenter
of the outbreak planes flying in and out
of the mainland are being deep cleaned
and disinfected while shopping centers a
user
thermal-imaging cameras to test for
those who may have a fever hand
sanitizers are a common sight so too are
masks and Bangkok's Chinatown which is
one of the biggest Chinese enclaves in
the world it's both a major tourist
attraction and popular with locals I've
seen a decline in the number of tourists
especially in the past few days since
the news broke about the virus when
Chinese tourists easier some type II
won't come because they're scared of
getting infected while people try
everything they can to protect
themselves they're looking to doctors
and scientists around the world who were
urgently trying to find a solution to a
problem that's growing by the day
Alexey O'Brien al Jazeera Bangkok